tengo las gráficas de tres funciones por
aquí y nos dicen que una de ellas
representa la función f otra su primera
derivada y la última su segunda derivada
y no sabemos cuál es cuál así que como
siempre pausa este vídeo e intenta
encontrar la relación bueno es momento
de trabajarlo juntos y la forma en la
que voy a abordar este ejercicio será
intentar dibujar cómo se ve la derivada
de cada una de estas gráficas así que en
esta gráfica de color anaranjado puedo
decir que la pendiente es muy positiva
en un principio y después se hace menos
y menos y menos positiva hasta este
punto donde la pendiente va a ser igual
a cero y después se hace más y más y más
negativa así que la derivada de la
función que está representada por esta
curva se va a ver así va a empezar muy
positiva en este punto y la pendiente va
a ser cero justo aquí así que aquí
tenemos que cruzar el eje x y después va
a ser más y más y más negativa hasta
dejar el intervalo que podemos ver de
modo que se va a ver más o menos así no
sé si en efecto sea una recta o algo
parecido pero va a ser un tipo de curva
que tenga una tendencia con esta forma
por lo que en definitiva podemos decir
que esta gráfica de azul no es la
derivada de la función de color a
naranja
observa que en este intervalo la
tendencia es justo lo contrario va de
negativo a positivo cuando debería de
ser de positivo a negativo así que
podemos descartarla como su derivada y
qué pasa con esta gráfica magenta bueno
en este pedazo parece que tiene la
tendencia correcta
ínter seca al eje x en ese sitio que
parece ser el mismo de la gráfica
original y al menos para este intervalo
parece que es positiva de aquí aquí
cuando ocurre lo mismo con la pendiente
de la recta tangente de la primera
gráfica y es negativa cuando la
pendiente de la recta tangente de la
primera gráfica lo es también ahora algo
que me causa malestar sobre el
razonamiento de que la última gráfica
sea la derivada de la primera es que no
hemos usado la idea de que la derivada
tiene más puntos extremos es decir más
máximos o mínimos que la función
original pero en este caso podría ser
que no los vemos porque tal vez no vemos
la primera función completa por ejemplo
si
esta tercera gráfica fuera en efecto la
derivada de la primera entonces
tendríamos que después de este punto la
pendiente cambiaría a ser menos negativa
entonces la primera función tendría una
gráfica cuya pendiente de la recta
tangente después de este punto sería
cada vez menos negativa hasta que en
este punto la pendiente sería cero y por
lo tanto podemos decir que nuestra
gráfica se tendría que ver más o menos
así lo cual no vemos porque tal vez sólo
nos muestran un pedazo de la gráfica no
la muestran completa por lo tanto
podemos decir que esta tercera gráfica
es una buena candidata para hacer la
derivada de la primera así que tal vez
podríamos decir que esta es efe y que
ésta es f prima
ahora veamos qué es lo que pasa con la
segunda como se ve su derivada bueno
pues empezamos con una pendiente muy
negativa que cada vez se hace menos
negativa hasta llegar a este punto donde
cero por lo tanto nuestra derivada
debería interceptar al eje x justo aquí
empezaría siendo negativa y cada vez
sería menos negativa hasta llegar a este
punto y después de este punto cruzamos
al eje x hasta tener una pendiente más y
más positiva hasta que por aquí deja de
ser cada vez más positiva y empieza a
tener una pendiente cada vez menos
positiva hasta que por aquí deja de ser
cada vez más positiva y empieza a tener
una pendiente cada vez menos positiva
así que la derivada se vería más o menos
así hasta que aquí se vea cada vez menos
positiva menos positiva
menos positiva hasta que kim la
pendiente sea cero de nuevo por lo tanto
nuestra derivada intersec a al eje x
justo allí y después la pendiente de la
recta tangente toma valores más y más y
más negativos y por lo tanto la derivada
es más y más
negativa por lo cual la gráfica que
acabo de esbozar es muy parecida a la
gráfica que tenemos en primer lugar por
lo tanto la gráfica anaranjada me parece
en efecto la derivada de la gráfica de
azul puedo decir que de hecho esta va a
ser entonces mi gráfica efe la gráfica
de anaranjado va a ser f prima y si
estás efe prima la derivada de ella
sería f mi prima así que parece que ya
estamos bien pero para estar más seguros
podemos hacer lo mismo para esta tercera
gráfica esbocemos su derivada la
pendiente de mi recta tangente observa
es positiva pero cada vez menos hasta
llegar a cero justo aquí por lo que la
derivada se vería más o menos así y
después la pendiente de mi recta
tangente es menos y menos y menos
negativa hasta llegar a este punto así
que la derivada es más negativa y en
este punto la pendiente de la recta
tangente es cada vez menos negativa de
tal manera que llegamos a este punto
donde de nuevo tomamos el valor de cero
y después la pendiente es cada vez más
así que la derivada de esta curva
magenta se debería de ver más o menos
así como una que abre hacia arriba y
observa no vemos esto aquí así que
podemos sentirnos bien de que la
derivada no aparezca con esto podemos ya
estar seguros de nuestra conclusión la
gráfica de enmedio la llamaremos efe la
primera gráfica será f prima y la
tercera gráfica será fbi prima hasta la
próxima